there's three possibilities if someone
ends up wealthy basically they inherited
it they're a crook and by the way let me
tell you both of those are very low
percentage of wealthy people but most of
the time wealth like happiness is never
attained when sought after directly it
is a byproduct of providing a useful
service if you run a successful
restaurant and do a good job you're
providing a useful service I want to go
over there and get a nice warm meal and
pay a fair amount for that meal and get
service and then the waiter or waitress
brings us the food and smiles and puts
water in the glass and we have a good
experience and you do that a whole lot
then you build wealth over time by the
way if you're able to do that for two
restaurants instead of one you help and
serve twice as many people and you make
twice as much money if you did it with
ten restaurants instead of one meaning
it being good service and good food and
quality and a smile and the water glass
is full then you would make ten times
what somebody that has one restaurant
has and so some people make ten times
more than other people make but it
usually has to do with the fact that
they provide ten times more service to
the economy in one way or another that
may not be service you particularly
agree with or appreciate but that
doesn't matter the economy is willing to
pay the person for that service the
marketplace is willing to pay them for
that service and so wealth will never be
equal wealth equality is mythology
because no two
people bring the same level of service
to the marketplace the same level of
good looks intelligence relational
ability education effort hours no two
people can match that exactly the same
and so no two people make exactly the
same throughout the scope of their life
nor should they make the same if you
work twice as hard as I work and you
make an a on a test and I make a C
because I goofed off why would it be
fair to give me an A just so that we're
both equal really what we're saying is
is that equal is unfair
given that effort is never equal talent
is never equal intellect is never equal
and so even if those things are not
equal then Y would equal pay be fair
it's actually unfair the whole wealth
equality movement is unfair have you
ever thought about that way it's
interesting to think about it is why the
best and brightest among us will never
tolerate socialism or communism because
it's not fair you need to pay your fair
share
really well let's investigate paying
your fair share 48% of Americans last
year paid no federal income tax so how
is that fair how is that fair now if you
make 10 times more and you paid 10 times
more in tax that would be fair but that
would assume that someone actually paid
tax and 48 percent don't pay any tax as
a matter of fact there's a percentage of
our American public that gets what's
called an unearned income tax credit let
me help you with that let's listen to
those words carefully unearned
income tax credit and what that is is
they didn't pay anything into the tax
system whatsoever and yet because of
their lower income and the size of their
families the government actually sends
them a check and so not only did they
not pay tax they received money from the
government now how is that fair well
it's not it's not fair see I'm perfectly
fine paying twenty times more if I make
twenty times more or 20 times less if I
make 20 times less and so if everybody
paid the same percentage that would be
okay I mean I can even make some
adjustments for the regressive fact of
the lower income folks you know when you
when you I made $6,000 one year that was
a great year you know I can even take
that out there as an idea and say well
you know we got to take care of let
people buy food before we you know the
basic level but say above a certain
income level and everybody above pick
out a number twenty thousand bucks or
something everybody above that is that's
a basic eating I mean that's you barely
can eat on that and so you know
everything above that it's going to be
taxed at the same rate so everybody pays
10% or 12% or 15% or 22% I don't care
but everybody pays that everybody pays
same percent and so if you make a
million dollars
you pay twenty two percent of it and if
you make a hundred thousand dollars you
pay twenty two percent of it and you
made 1/10 as much as the person that
makes a million and you paid 1/10 and
taxes as much let's see that seems fair
it's not equal but it's fair now my
advocating a flat tax no I'm just trying
to get you people to think again because
a bunch of you quit thinking you quit
using your brains and you need to think
you need to turn off CNN and Fox and
actually think have an original thought
that's not a soundbite we've lost the
ability to do critical thought in our
culture
maybe the sales tax is the answer the
national sales tax the fair tax it's
called maybe that's the answer I don't
know I don't care
and I don't even care that much about
the existing tax situation except that I
it really does chap me when people are
so freaking ignorant that they say pay
your fair share and the very guys saying
that is paying nothing and I pay a lot I
don't mind paying a lot I make a lot I'm
okay with that I do mind paid a lot
that's not true but I really really
really resent paying a lot and then
people wagging their little liberal
finger in my face and saying I'm not
paying my fair share because it's what's
known as freakin lie
you've lost your ability to do critical
thought in sixth-grade math because you
believe some political garbage
so wealth like happiness is never
attained when sought after directly it
is the byproduct of providing a useful
service and the more of a service you
provide to the marketplace the better
off you are
now as individuals we're all equal in
God's eyes meaning our value as a human
being is equal any question about that
but the service I provide of the
marketplace is not as much as Bill Gates
did so Bill Gates has more money so his
marketplace value is higher than mine
the service I provided the marketplace
is less than peyton manning and some of
you would argue no one should get paid
that for throwing a butt ball well
there's only one way you can solve that
and let's get people to quit paying for
people that throw footballs because when
we all walk into the stadium and we pay
it but by the way I love paying for that
because I love football and I'm glad
they make a lot of money because they
get punished but if you philosophically
disagree that professional athletes it's
just absurd
I mean teachers should make more than
athletes well that's up to the culture
in the marketplace to decide what
they're going to pay for these things
and when you choose to enter a field
that is not that does not pay that the
marketplace does not financially
appreciate you made that choice
and so you don't have the ability to
philosophically get on your high horse
and yell at the culture because we're
all too stupid for you're a Christian
okay Krista Craddock mindset so
something to think about so equal is not
fair and fair is not equal
you